[Music]
all right let's go to amygdala in
baltimore
what's going on
hi thank you for taking my call of
course it's mcdolly all right mcdolly i
knew yeah i knew that yeah
oh i you know what i keep i was thinking
about amygdal i'm sorry i trolled john i
got to be honest before we went on air i
just kept saying amygdala amygdala
amygdala thinking he would screw it up
and that was right well done george
there you go what's your name he's one
of my best friends and that's what
friends do so what's up
so um my husband is being extremely
insistent on my taking money out of my
um
retirement in order to cover um
immediate costs that we have to
um bring income in during the summer as
well as then possibly
um
take care of some more debt
are you guys retired
no how old are you
i'm i'm actually 60 um and i've been
home um i've been home with the children
for the last 10 years
um and um have just started looking at
the possibility of i've been exploring
jobs i'm working on my resume
um and i have lots of experience so i
think i would be able to get a job
um
and i actually have up until i left work
i was always a higher earner
in our family
um
and
i
don't want to take money out of my
retirement to cover um the next couple
of months um
is this an emergency situation do you
guys not have enough income to cover
your bills
that is correct
wow what happened what happened
we're not on same page
we you know i do the budget and say this
is what it is and we just don't connect
um
my other hesitancy is um about four or
five years ago
i think about that time i
um agreed that i would pull out a
hundred thousand from my retirement
to get us completely out of debt
and that lasted about a year and then we
rested that up again
mcdonald's
you're talking kind of around the
situation um
is your husband out of control with the
spending
i believe he is he doesn't see he is but
i do believe because here's what i'm
hearing i'm hearing that you are
you are financially secure you're very
very smart you make you're very very
wise
and you have an adult that you share
life with who's acting like a child when
it comes to money and he's put you all
in a position where you're not safe and
you're being very careful they're not
saying that so i'm saying it so tell me
if i'm wrong or if i'm if i'm right
you're absolutely right okay and i've
been very uneasy over the last couple of
weeks thinking there's something going
on and i couldn't quite put my finger on
it
and i had already decided to give you
guys a call
and in today's mail
it looks like he took out ten thousand
dollars out last year on his retirement
front that he's paying but i didn't i
just found out what is he buying so
because this sounds very much either one
of two things he's really struggling
with an addiction or he's seeing
somebody else
well i found out well just like two
years ago that he did have an affair he
broke that off
my thought is that he's doing um
you know this bitcoin and things like
that that i don't agree with and somehow
he's gonna stretch it rich fast
and so that's another issue because i
don't believe it works that way
um okay so you have to work and you have
to have a plan yes you are yes and once
again you are the adult and you're being
very very wise um
around here we call this financial
infidelity on top of true infidelity and
it's very very rare that somebody's just
out of control to the tune of the money
you're saying
and they're just buying
i mean they may have like a hoarding
issue right that's very that's rare
um this sounds like something else is
going on i want you to hear me say you
are not safe in this relationship
um you're going to end up in a
major financial mess and my guess is if
you go spelunking and go
on an investigative
journey here you're gonna find a lot of
junk
okay
this is a
stop all the presses
um we're gonna see a marriage counselor
before this week is over if you want to
stay in this marriage this is a scary
proposition for you and i'm
i think there's more to this story than
you
either want to believe or that you want
to say over the radio or you've chosen
to not go digging because you're afraid
of what you might find
i i think um i absolutely believe
there's more i think
everything in me tells me there's more
my priority is um to protect my children
correct correct and i think that i think
that is very very wise does he have
access to your retirement accounts
absolutely not okay
there is a zero percent chance none zero
do not take a penny out of a retirement
account
okay
for your sake and for your kid's sake do
not do that cool
yeah
absolutely and you know um i i believe
in you know dave ramsey and what he says
and even though
i've been out of work or not have been
out work i've stayed home um which i
truly believe is a calling from god to
take care of my children this way you
don't have to hey you don't have to
apologize you made a choice and it's
it's a good choice you did you did you
did well by you and your kids okay
you're not less than you didn't do
anything you may have a guy in your
house wanting you to go make some more
money that he can go blow on
whatever the crap he wants to buy and he
may have beat you down with that over
the last few years but
good for you i'm glad you made a good
choice for you and your kids um
but your marriage is on
very very thin ice and you know that
right
absolutely i do okay it's time to
address that head on because this is
this is part of money conversation but
this is a much much bigger deal
so is he the only one earning income
right now do you have income outside of
his
no and that's why over the last couple
of weeks i've started putting the word
out i'm working on a resume um so that i
can actually start um doing hopefully
some part-time work you've heard the
dave ramsey um
gazelle intensity
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
this is gazelle intense about you
getting an income
okay you aren't safe in the situation
you are in
and i'm telling you this because i love
you and i'm frustrated that that
somebody has treated you this way
i'm also frustrated that you have
everything you've told me about your
professional life about your parenting
about you are very very wise and for
some reason you've chosen to not listen
to
yourself on this one
and i want you to start listening to you
on this one because you're right
you know how bad this is don't you
i do you do okay
for you are worth more than this mess
okay
thank you are you how old are your kids
i have um uh 13
and 14 year old
and my our oldest son is 19 and
is a rising sophomore in college okay
yeah it is it's man you got i didn't
realize you had minors in the house yeah
you've got to get on top of this asap
i'm going to gift you a few things
mcdonald's yeah we're going to give you
ken coleman from paycheck to purpose
book along with his get clear assessment
and his resume templates to help you
jump start this career and get some
income in the door so that you can take
care of yourself so sorry for what
you're going through i want you to get a
friend or two
tell them everything that's going on
because you're gonna need some people to
walk alongside you as you enter into
what's gonna be a really tough season
moving forward there will be light on
the back end of this thing
we'll walk alongside you give us a call
if we can help